[Música]
Buenos días y gracias por estar con
nosotros en esta entrevista para France
24 y radiofrance internacional estamos
en kiev para una edición especial
dedicada a este país en guerra en las
puertas de la Unión Europea y en
compañía del presidente del Consejo
europeo Charles Michell Buenos días
Buenos días
Quisiera empezar mencionando que usted
es belga que fue Primer Ministro y que
ya ha venido cuatro veces a kiev para
hablar con los ucranianos que aspiran a
entrar a la Unión Europea me gustaría
preguntarle cómo ve kiev en vísperas del
primer aniversario de esta incierta
guerra
se aceptan es una ciudad que está en
guerra es un país que está en guerra
viene aquí varias veces antes de que
comenzara esta brutal invasión en
febrero del año pasado y el contraste es
obviamente impactante es esencial que la
Unión Europea se muestre firme unida que
apoye a Ucrania pero también que ejerza
presión posible sobre el kremlin
el presidente insiste en que se inician
las negociaciones de adhesiones de año
ya que son candidatos desde junio del
año pasado aquí le gustaría acelerar el
proceso y a usted
creo que nos conviene apoyar los
esfuerzos ucranianos en la medida de lo
posible consideramos que existe una
voluntad política muy firme de llevar a
cabo las reformas necesarias en solo
unos meses desde que se les concedió el
estatus de candidatos el pasado mes de
junio ya han dado pasos importantes en
materia de reformas para reforzar el
estado de derecho la lucha contra la
corrupción y la independencia del poder
judicial Claro que todavía queda mucho
camino por recorrer pero apoyemos con
firmeza los ucranianos en su sincero
deseo de entrar a la Unión Europea se
dice que una Cumbre entre la Unión
Europea y Ucrania en kiev es una señal
fuerte pero de qué es señal es señal de
la europea también es señal de unidad
cuando nos encontramos ante esta brutal
agresión de Rusia comprendimos
inmediatamente que este será un punto de
inflexión en la historia de Europa y que
este punto de inflexión requería que los
líderes europeos estuvieran a la altura
de las circunstancias y así es como se
definió inmediatamente la estrategia
máximo apoyo financiero humanitario
político y militar a los ucranianos y al
mismo tiempo una movilización escala
internacional para tratar de aislar a
Rusia y demostrar que está flagrante
violación del derecho internacional
cometida por Rusia es una amenaza para
todo el mundo la Unión Europea considera
que si se suma su contribución a la de
los estados miembros en todos los campos
militares civil etcétera ha destinado
casi 60.000 millones de euros en ayudas
a Ucrania esta cifra Sigue estando por
detrás de la de Estados Unidos no es un
poco decepcionante para una guerra que
ocurre en nuestro suelo no Esa no es la
realidad por un lado pagamos un precio
económico mucho más alto que Estados
Unidos porque ellos son un país
exportador de recursos energéticos todos
sabemos que hay turbulencias en el
frente energético en Europa pero la
Unión Europea está actuando para
intentar de influir tanto en el
suministro como en los precios Todavía
queda trabajo por hacer en los últimos
meses con respecto a este tema Luego si
sumamos la cuestión de la crisis de los
refugiados ucranianos varios millones de
refugiados ucranianos se encuentran en
Europa más que ninguna otra parte del
mundo lo que es normal vemos que estamos
más o menos en igualdad de condiciones
en cuanto a las capacidades financieras
que se movilizan el ejército ucraniano
va a recibir entrenamiento para usar
tanques leopard alemanes cada estado
miembro contribuye en función de las
decisiones nacionales sobre armamento
dado que usted se encarga de
coordinarlos en cierta medida influye
sobre esa decisión habla con ellos para
decirles tenemos que entregar este o
aquel equipo desde la primera hora del
estallido de la guerra tomamos medidas
para coordinar a los 27 estados miembros
en términos apoyo militar fue la Unión
Europea y no la otan algunos se les
olvida la que movilizó en las horas
siguientes al estallido de esta invasión
el fondo europeo de apoyo a la paz un
instrumento financiero para el que ya se
han movilizado un total de 12 mil
millones de euros una parte con fondos
de la Unión Europea otra parte con
fondos nacionales y en cada etapa
Tratamos de coordinar desde luego los
estados miembros actúan según sus medios
sus capacidades Pero hay una dinámica
muy coordinada en el plan de apoyo
militares
usted dice que no le corresponde a la
otan Pero se tiene la impresión de que
esta guerra enterró un poco la idea de
que hay una defensa europea muy
estructurada desde cierto punto de vista
ahora estamos más dispuestos a
refugiarnos debajo del paraguas de la
otan que antes en mi opinión es
exactamente lo contrario creo que la
defensa europea nació realmente a raíz
de esta invasión cuando por primera vez
en la historia la Unión Europea decide
entregar armas algo que nunca había
sucedido para empezar cuando unas
semanas después de la invasión los 27
dirigentes europeos decidieron acelerar
la defensa europea fomentando la
cooperación Industrial trabajando como
lo estamos haciendo en este momento para
aumentar la producción de municiones en
Europa con el fin de abastecer nuestras
reservas y poder seguir apoyando a los
ucranianos creo que la historia mostrará
Cuando haya un poco más de retrospectiva
que esta guerra nos ha abierto los ojos
ante la urgencia y la necesidad de
actuar en pro de una defensa europea en
conexión con la otan en coherencia con
la otan y también para tener más
autonomía estratégica respecto a la
Unión Europea al mismo tiempo países
como Suecia y Finlandia aspiran a entrar
en la otan y Turquía aprovecha para
imponer su ley especialmente a Suecia a
quien le pide que deporte a todos los
disidentes Incluyendo los periodistas
esta política
incomoda bastante a Suecia se menciona
poco que Turquía también es un país
candidato a entrar en la Unión Europea
aunque las negociaciones estén
congeladas este factor Turco está
perturbando el juego
lo que es cierto En todo caso es que
este es un debate que debe darse en la
otan más que en la Unión Europea Pero
también es cierto que como Unión Europea
defendemos la libres decisiones tomadas
por Finlandia y Suecia y Esperamos que
se encuentren soluciones lo antes
posible he tenido conversaciones
frecuentes con el secretario general de
la otan sobre este tema y Esperamos que
en los próximos meses se produzca
algunas aclaraciones al respecto pero en
todo caso esto muestra un punto
importante que lo que consiguió Vladimir
Putin es lo contrario de lo que quería
esperaba dividir la Unión Europea
dividir a los estadounidenses y a los
europeos y en realidad consiguió una
Unión Europea más grande con el proceso
de ampliación con Ucrania montavia
Georgia y también consiguió la
ampliación de la otan con dos países de
la Unión Europea que decidieron
presentar su candidatura para entrar en
la
al mismo tiempo lo que está haciendo
Turquía no es presionar a Suecia para
que le dé la espalda a los valores
europeos y como presidente del consejo
le preocupa que retrocedamos en esto
confío plenamente en el liderazgo sueco
y finlandés hay una gran determinación
para defender los valores comunes de la
Unión Europea y es cierto que en el caso
de la otan la posición de Turquía frena
la capacidad de estos dos países para
entrar en la otan soy optimista creo que
podemos resolver esta cuestión y espero
que los próximos meses aporten más
claridad al respecto
de Rusia en vísperas del aniversario del
24 de febrero
La respuesta es Sí porque el mundo ha
visto que el ejército ruso no es lo que
el mundo se imaginaba pudimos observar
que aunque los rusos probablemente se
imaginaban que en pocas semanas Ucrania
colapsaría esto no fue lo que ocurrió
así que efectivamente existe el riesgo
de que quieran vengarse existe el riesgo
del símbolo del primer año tras la
invasión y por eso abogué porque se
reforzará el suministro de armas
que se reforzara el apoyo a Ucrania y
por eso también esta Cumbre estamos aquí
en kiev para demostrar que apoyamos
firmemente a los ucranianos
el efecto que esta guerra tiene nuestra
sociedad Es evidente
en Francia por ejemplo la gente está muy
afectada por la pérdida de poder
adquisitivo debido a la crisis
energética la Unión Europea logrará
resolver también la cuestión de la
pobreza generada por esta crisis
energética
y sobre todo no se está hundiendo en un
cierto populismo
es decir la democracias se están
tambaleando
un año después del estallido de la
guerra me sorprende positivamente El
Fuerte apoyo de las opiniones y
poblaciones europeas como lo muestran
todas las encuestas hay un apoyo muy
grande hacia la estrategia de unidad de
la Unión Europea en apoyo de Ucrania y
de dureza frente al kremlin esto no
impide que los extremistas populistas
exploten esta situación pero la
responsabilidad de los dirigentes
europeos responsables que debemos ser es
movilizar todos los esfuerzos para
resolver estas cuestiones económicas que
son la garantía de nuestra protección
social en toda Europa por eso el consejo
europeo los 27 jefes de estado le
pidieron a la comisión con carácter de
urgencia quisiera propuestas para apoyar
la base Industrial quisiera propuestos
para ir más lejos en cuanto a medidas de
protección del poder adquisitivo sobre
todo en el contexto de la crisis
energética
dentro de unas semanas la comisión
tendrá que poner sobre la mesa una
propuesta de reforma del mercado de la
electricidad
este es uno de los elementos que
demuestran que hay una gran lucidez por
parte de los dirigentes europeos una
gran conciencia de nuestras
responsabilidades
Es cierto que no es fácil pero a menudo
en el pasado hemos visto que la Unión
Europea crece cuando se enfrenta a
obstáculos cuando hay crisis y estas
crisis nos impulsan a recurrir a nuestra
capacidad de trabajar juntos
los ucranianos esperan un nuevo paquete
de sanciones el décimo y consideran como
lo repitió el presidente zelenski que la
Unión Europea tiende a ir despacio
mientras Rusia acelera la guerra
probablemente por sus divisiones
internas
anteriormente habló de unidad pero del
lado de la Hungría de Víctor urbano no
siempre se está de acuerdo con las
sanciones en materia de energía pues
depende mucho de Rusia otros países
también se muestran muy reticentes en
otros temas
considera que no se Está avanzando al
ritmo óptimo de nuestra unidad
tengo dos puntos primero la Unión
Europea es una democracia así que
combates hay deliberaciones se toman
decisiones segundo encuentro las
sanciones hemos adoptado nueve paquetes
de sanciones decididos por unanimidad
son paquetes sumamente duros para el
kremlin para Rusia que tienen un impacto
que afecta directamente las capacidades
tecnológicas y que afecta directamente
la capacidad de generar ingresos del
kremling tienen un impacto pero es
cierto que cada paquete adicional
requiere una negociación adicional
porque no todos los estados miembro
tienen el mismo Punto de partida en
cuanto a los asuntos sectoriales que son
objeto de sanciones
una de las polémicas en este momento es
el futuro de los atletas rusos que
participarán en los Juegos Olímpicos de
París los países bálticos a Polonia
piden que se les prohíba participar es
decir un boicot Cuál es su posición
quisiera que hubiera unidad europea al
respecto pero este debate aún no se ha
abierto al menos no en el consejo
europeo Así que no quiero expresarme
públicamente sobre este tema porque creo
que es el momento de promover una
posición común el deporte también es
política creo que es normal que se
plantee la pregunta no es sorprendente
que se plantee el debate pero no quiero
adelantarme a lo que podría ser una
decisión además tenemos consultas
internas del g7 con nuestros socios y no
debemos permitir que este tema nos
divida sino intentar forjar opiniones
unidas también en ese tema
la Cumbre europea en Bruselas entre el
presidente y la presidenta de la
comisión Úrsula Wonder Legend usted
mismo el jefe de la diplomacia Joseph
borrell Acaso no hay demasiados
diplomáticos cuando se trata de la
diplomacia y la representación de la
Unión Europea en Ucrania y de la gestión
de este conflicto
no lo creo porque tenemos que estar muy
movilizados para convencer al mundo
entero de apoyar la estrategia de
proteger el derecho internacional además
la Unión Europea se basa en una doble
legitimidad por un lado el parlamento
europeo y la comisión encarnan el
interés común de la Unión Europea por el
otro los estados miembros en sus
procesos democráticos desempeñan un
papel clave a la hora de impulsar
decisiones dentro de la Unión Europea lo
que importa es la unidad Y eso es lo que
hemos demostrado hasta ahora
se reunió con Georgia es la jefa de
gobierno de Italia hubo mucha
preocupación cuando ella llegó al poder
porque es más bien de la familia de la
extrema derecha teme que Italia vaya por
su propia cuenta
especialmente en la cuestión ucraniana
Porque algunos de sus partidos en
coalición presionan para minimizar las
sanciones
cuando hay un gobierno con una coalición
necesariamente hay sensibilidades dentro
de un gobierno lo que está muy claro es
que 100 días después de que tomara el
poder hemos visto una voluntad de
responsabilidad a nivel europeo he
tenido la oportunidad de trabajar con la
señora meloni desde que asumió su cargo
y siempre he visto un enfoque
constructivo de su parte a la hora de
posiciones comunes en el consejo europeo
me reuní con ella para preparar el
próximo consejo europeo que tendrá lugar
en Bruselas y que tiene en su agenda
temas importantes el tema económico y
también el de la migración soy optimista
sobre los deseos del gobierno de la
señora meloni de estar en un proceso de
convergencia europea
Precisamente en materia de migración
Italia actúa por su propia cuenta
dificultando enormemente el rescate de
migrantes por parte de las ong no está
esto también un poco en la línea Roja de
los valores de la Unión Europea las
operaciones de búsqueda y salvamiento
que Italia hace en el Mediterráneo no
datan de la llegada de la señora melonio
es un tema que viene planteándose desde
hace varios años y es normal que los
distintos estados europeos reflexionen
en Cómo quieren enfocar esta
concertación esta cooperación con las
ong en el marco del respeto al derecho
internacional además lo que ha observado
es que existe una voluntad compartida de
intentar forzar las labores de
coordinación para prevenir el riesgo de
tensiones entre los estados miembro en
este tipo de circunstancias el qatargate
ha afectado mucho al parlamento europeo
por supuesto es un escándalo de
corrupción y aquí también me gustaría
preguntarle como presidente del Consejo
no habría que darle ejemplo a todas las
instituciones por ejemplo estaría usted
a favor de una alta autoridad de
autorregulación de la vida pública a
escala europea que sea independiente de
todas las instituciones incluido de su
consejo parece que cuando hay un
escándalo de corrupción surge la idea de
crear una institución adicional Yo diría
que hay que vigilar las normas y
funcionan la corrupción es un delito es
reprensible penalmente el sistema
judicial cumple su trabajo de su país
Por cierto la justicia belga Sí pero
podría ser la justicia de otro país sin
embargo es cierto que hay que tener
normas muy estrictas Y que debe haber
una concertación entre las distintas
instituciones para mejorar
sistemáticamente la transparencia y la
prevención de este tipo de situaciones
lo que me parece positivo sin embargo
decir que tenemos que crear un nuevo
instrumento o comprobar si los
instrumentos existentes deberían
movilizarse más es una cuestión que
deberían debatir las instituciones señor
presidente el veinticuatro de febrero es
el aniversario de la guerra un año
después Cuál es su mensaje para el
pueblo ucraniano resiste estamos con
ustedes su destino es la Unión Europea
Porque esa es su elección su decisión y
realmente pueden contar con la
determinación europea porque sabemos que
están sufriendo están sufriendo para
defender Su futuro y para defender a sus
hijos pero también están sufriendo para
defender los valores en los que creemos
Gracias Michelle por haber estado con
nosotros Gracias a ustedes por habernos
visto sigan en nuestra sintonía
[Música]